[Music]
hello again I'm Dustin Kirkland and I'm
here with Maya catcher offski she is the
security product manager for containers
at Google and we're gonna talk a bit
about the security angle here at Kubb
con and I think she's got a pretty
exciting announcement from earlier today
yeah that's right so Google communities
engine information about clusters are
now included in the cloud security
command center the cloud security
command center is our single pane of
glass for figuring out what's happening
in your projects from a security point
of view think about a security
monitoring rather than say application
monitoring and now you can see what's
happening for those gke clusters right
in cloud CSEC what's really exciting
about that also is that we have five
container security partner integrations
natively in gke in cloud security
command center can you name all five yes
aqua security capsulate stack rocks
Cystic secure and twist lock all can now
write their their findings directly to
the cloud security command center for
what you're running in decay now is that
run time or is that at build or
developer time what's the sure so we
think about container security at Google
and three different aspects one is what
we'll call making sure your containers
are secured to develop so do I have some
way of managing my network policies and
secrets and and different kinds of
deployment policies identities etc and I
only need to have the second area is
what we'll call build and deploy
security so how do you know that your
images are vulnerability free don't
maintain O'Day's right that they gone
through your CI CT pipeline before that
employed to production right the main
thing that we have in that space right
now something called graph is it's an
open source project there's a couple
talks actually at cube con Agra fayus by
the TL of that project okay Wendy and
that allows you to track the metadata of
your projects including vulnerability
scan results for those images so you can
then determine whether or not you can
deploy those images kubernetes at large
it seems like there's a lot of work
that's gone into more secure images
without zero-days it seems like
something that we've really got to get
on top of right it's it's certainly an
area with a lot of low-hanging fruit and
there's a lot of customer and and
partner interest in that space the main
the main problem is all
that space right now is just the sheer
volume of vulnerability some people have
so I've had customers ask me how do i
you know what do I do if I find a
vulnerability that doesn't have a patch
that exists yet and the reality is
you're probably not you're thinking too
far ahead right you probably have a ton
of vulnerabilities that are completely
untouched right fix those first before
you start to worry about things that are
unpatch well so is the best advice we
have to give is rely on the operating
systems vendors to provide those updates
and just make sure that those updates
are as as installed as possible in all
of your base images so you're thinking
of it actually differently or than what
I'm thinking okay so you can talk about
the the the note OS and the container
West Google uses we use container
optimized OS at the note OS right is
open source based on chromium OS right
and we even have a great blog post as to
why we think that's it's built in a
really secure way and then you can use
the the container OS and we have lots of
options again on Google or you can bring
your own right and then we have the
image it's all for your deploying and
that might itself have vulnerabilities
right so if you're running nginx but
you're running or WordPress that's a to
your two-year-old you know image right
maybe you want to patch that before you
deploy you want to check the age of your
images maybe want to run some standard
scans excetera before you deploy that
and which of those is the users
responsibility versus Google takes care
of on your behalf sure if you're using a
connote OS or container us that's
provided by Google okay it's Google's
responsibility to patch it but it's your
responsibility pick what you want okay
so these are pics and the Google handles
the patching of the base OS as a managed
service effective if they pick an OS
that we provided okay so if you if you
choose to bring your own container OS
sure then it's your responsibility
okay viously the image OS is your
responsibility to - sorry the image
itself is a responsibility to secure
okay but this single pane of glass now
should maybe help users of it Wow so
that's the third area that's our
container runtime security area which is
I have a container now running in
production and I've done everything I
can to you know fiddle with all the
things in gke and and scan Miami just
before they're deployed but what if what
if there still isn't O'Dea and what if
somebody gets into my container and
center's doing something bad
how do I detect that react do forensics
after the fact etc yeah and that's
container runtime security okay and
that's a super nascent space
we realized there's a lot of interest in
hence the integrations of five partners
with the Cloud Security commencement
right you know are any of these helping
us with forensics I'm guessing that
snapshot in the container knowing what
it looked like at various points in time
maybe being able to roll back debug logs
and monitoring logs and I don't know
trace the origin ation of the attack
that's the still fairly new capability a
lot of thinking right yeah a lot of the
partners have tooling around a longer
set of logs so you might have logs that
are written temporarily to like a ring
buffer for example and then once you
detect them incident you flag those logs
can start writing those right it's not
necessarily like full image snapshotting
all right it's happening yet that's
where we're at today so we covered the
three different areas I'm curious if
there are kinds of attacks that you'd
like to maybe highlight the types of
things that either developers should be
aware of when writing an application or
IT administrators should be aware of as
they're operating clusters yeah I mean
it's implement its kind of boring for
security professional it's not that
different than what you see is attacking
a VM right you're gonna see credential
theft privilege escalation you might see
abuse of compute in this case crypto
mining is a fairly popular thing to do
yeah they're not new kinds of attacks
and often people are actually not aware
that they're in a container when they're
in attacks they're not attacking
kubernetes per se right they're just
attacking some open compute thing and oh
I happened to be in a container like
that's great indeed interesting so
different question moving away from
security a little bit just looking at
the community the at large community and
around kubernetes are there maybe any
people individuals in the community that
you'd like to recognize as someone who
inspires you is maybe helped you out or
helped out the project in the in the
last few months yeah I think we're
really fortunate in security everyone
who's involved in insig off is really a
stellar stellar individual I'd like to
call out like Eric Chang from Red Hat
core West's he's been really great at
doing a lot of the I am Auerbach type
work in
in kubernetes if you want a good
description of our back go talk to Eric
it will explain it to you just about
that 30 seconds or an hour long
depending on what you like and and what
he does or doesn't like about our back
Eric's also been leading a lot of the
thought leadership and saga' so that's
been really great to have to have him
involved yeah it's great then finding
finally one last question
can you tell us people are super
interested how you got into kubernetes
what was your introduction to kubernetes
people people are not super interested
oh they're very um I'm a very pragmatic
person I worked in security for a while
and I wanted to work on something that I
thought was gonna 10x in the next five
years
containers are gonna 10x in about five
years there will be security problems
there you go we can I also job security
and ideally we can prevent those
security problems before they happen all
right well good well thank you very much
thank you